Mike you're a nice guy thank you sir
thank you very much but not everyone is
as nice as you that's true I think it's
important to let the audience know who's
being nice and who's being not nice in
our very first dustbins called nice not
nice nice marine lepen
she's French she's blond and she hates
Muslims she's a triple threat will be
not nice marine world the whales or
sixes the Dolphins are fours and the
only tens of the Penguins and they're
all married
nice my lovely daughter Ivanka her skin
is like Italian marble and her hair is
like really great hair
not nice the German people who booed her
when she defended me at a conference in
Berlin disgusting this is the worst
thing the Germans have ever done nice
clam chowder
cook creamy hot I could drink it with a
straw not ice corn chowder
it's fake chowder fake chowder you're
taking jobs away from hard-working plan
this American corn äj-- and now I'm
gonna mix it up gonna mix it up Oh
mix it up are you ready already I'm
mixing it up ready pretty nice fresh
secretary Sean Spicer
he's a muttering slobber mouth with a
taste for his own foot why why don't I
fire this guy nice Sean Spicer TV
ratings I can't fire this guy his
ratings are tremendous
we love ratings and spicier brings them
in